كل مكان في هذا المخيم يعرف الطفل ادريس
وادريس هو الغريب عن المكان اليوم بعد عام
من الجفاف وسوء التغذيه الذي افقده الحركه
والاوضاع المعيشيه الصعبه اليسرته تحول
دون توفير الغذاء المناسب
مستشفى
[موسيقى]
الا عنده 50 حاله للسوء التغذيه تتم
معاينتها يوميا في مركز صحي واحد تحاله
بعضها للرقود فيما سجل مخيم الجفينه
المعدل الاعلى بمئه واحد 131 حاله لسوء
التغذيه الحاد العام الماضي
همم اريج ناصر من مخيم الجفينه تعاني من
سوء تغذيه مع مضاعفات عمرها شهرين وزنها
وكيله فاصل اثنين واكثر النازحين ياتون من
مخيم الجفيناه ففي عام 2022 من شهر واحد
لا نهايه عام 2022 معانا حاله تغذيه من
مخيم الكفيله 131 طفل طوابيره من الاطفال
بانتظار الخضوع لبرامج علاجيه في وحدات
صحيه تبنتها المنظمات الدوليه ثم تخلت
مؤخرا عن تشغيلها بحجه نقص التمويل ما
تزالوا تعملوا الى اليوم دون توفير
مستحقاتك وادرها الطبيه حالات التغذيه في
تزايد كل يوم في تزايد بيستقبل كثير
العديد من الاطفال في بعض الاحيان نحول
حالات الركود حالات الوخيم ثلاث الى خمس
حالات ركوب همم في بعض الاحيان لا يستطيع
القسمه الداخلي استيعاب كل الاطفال اللي
تتم حالتهم تحذيرات طول المنظمات الدوليه
من زياده حالات سوء التغذيه تؤكدها
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه والمعيشيه في اليمن
ارقام هي الاكبر وتسجل لحالات سوء التغذيه
في اليمن ومعاناه هي الاوسع منذ بدء الحرب
مع تردد الوضع الانساني والمعيشي خصوصا في
مخيمات النزوح محمود الحميدي لقناه
العربيه مارب